[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans l'épisode
final de la saison 2 de si on parlait
sport le rendez vous qu'il ne faut
absolument pas manquer si vous êtes un
accro à l'actualité sportive du
département
comme d'habitude il y aura des analyses
des débats et des duels de niveau à
champion's league
restez bien accroché quatre chroniqueurs
de légende son saut en plateau pendant
l'émission
ils ont travaillé toute la nuit pour
vous donner le meilleur d'eux-mêmes
présentation en musique
on commence par un mythes et légendes le
ce taux qu'ils étaient là lors de la
première émission il est toujours là
pour mettre le feu sur ce bateau il est
champion d'europe de cyclisme sur piste
master et biches champion du monde
je sais que cette émission ne peut que
rouler avec lui le capitaine ya
dujarrier du club de vélizy 78
et d'ajouter non sans mickaël ans ryan
alors prêt pour cette dernière édition
date étant déjà dernière émission ça
sera ça passe trop vite
non non je me disais il faut éviter de
les rater parce que finalement ça une
saison passe très vite
voilà où passe vite allons continuer à
ma droite à les professeurs de pole
dance à versailles ce sport qui mêle
danse et acrobatie autour d'une barre
c'est une redoutable chroniqueuse à la
rive à faire preuve de dextérité et de
souplesse intellectuelle pour faire
chavirer les duels pour sa faveur
notre ambassadrice de charme hélène de
la grand route avec nous pour cette
erreur bonsoir
hélène alors on est en plein été voilà
vous avez continué à faire quand même de
la pole dance on s'arrête jamais quand
on aime on s'arrête jamais claude cours
par contre assez toujours toujours
d'accord oui mais pendant l'été ah oui
je m'arrête le qu'un jour ça sera
suffisant
voilà bien une jarre les patates et ira
faire un tour s'ils s'ennuient voilà
c'est ça s'ils s'ennuient programme est
chargé
on repasse de l'autre côté musique on
termine
c'est là l'une des sciences du football
de la voile en passant par le golf et le
rugby sa spécialité reste le football
américain et les directeurs sportifs
chez les templiers d'elancourt
le professeur à frederick henderson est
avec nous bonjour frédéric alors c'est
un plaisir de vous recevoir une nouvelle
fois sur ses plateaux sur le cerveau de
cette émission vraiment voilà est ce que
pareil est ce que c'est bon de faire du
sport l'été oui bah c'est un jour
important de ne jamais arrêter de rester
en forme après il faut faire attention
avec la chaleur et bien boire bien
rester hydraté et si on voit des petits
soucis on sent pas bien des petits
vertige là il faut faire ce qu'on veut
stopper là il faut se reposer
tranquillement on repasse de l'autre
côté on termine peut-être par le
meilleur d'entre nous c'est une
véritable icône du rugby local c'est un
peu le sébastien chabal de plaisir mais
sans la barbe mais avant tout c'est un
passionné il respire à rugby ils mangent
rugby il est raide même de rugby quand
il dort mesdames et messieurs je vous
présente genlis bonne soirée cannes pour
son argent disent quand allez-vous pas
toujours en forme votre aide vraiment ô
combien ça ça vous serez virés ou bien
sûr vu j'ai bien suivi un rugby fait
partie intégrante de ma vie
effectivement tout le temps rugby oui
oui c'est vrai on comprend coupée et où
l'eau mais bon ça va faire du bien alors
avant de passer au programme de
l'émission j'aimerais qu'on parle de
handball féminin une nouvelle section va
se créer à la rentrée prochaine à ville
preuves sous l'impulsion de jeunes
sportifs venus de la ville qu'un jouet
se seraient déjà inscrits pour la
rentrée prochaine pour participer aux
entraînements en gymnase
alani moon l'équipe participera
également au championnat départemental
de handball
mais avant de parler de compétition les
filles préfèrent parler de cohésion en
écoute l'une des joueuses chloé roman on
va déjà essayer tout se connaître parce
que il y en a certaines ça fait des
années qu'on joue ensemble mais d'autres
on n'a jamais joué ses ailes sont plus
plus jeunes plus âgés donc on va déjà
tous apprendre à jouer ensemble ce qui
est super important
et ensuite
on pourra peut-être au bout d'un an
quand on aura aussi consolider l'équipe
et qu'on sera tous se connaître mais
pourquoi pas avoir enfin l'objectif est
d'avoir un bon niveau et de monter le
plus haut possible vient de jarrier que
pensez vous de cette nouvelle section a
dit le pr c'est très bien maintenant
c'est vrai que je me pose la question
comment aujourd'hui on
on arrive où on met en place un nouveau
produit dans une commune pour pour pour
dire on va créer donc une équipe
féminine alors prêtre qui a déjà un club
de hand sur sur cette commune c'est
masculin c'est juste une section
féminine qui se vend très bien faut il
faut encourager ce type d'initiative est
de toute façon le sport féminin en
particulier il faut l'encourager puisque
ben ça manque cruellement à tous a tout
fait dans le cyclisme en particulier on
en a on en souffre énormément et les
résultats au niveau international
en sont aussi une d une des raisons donc
voilà il faut encourager c'est tout
c'est toutes ces initiatives
et puis c'est très bien en plus de
pouvoir commencer comme ça à un petit
niveau et je pense que elle risque de
l'être d'être surprise en fin de saison
l'année prochaine on va les suivre avec
attention
on va laisser avec attention donc elles
ont déposé un dossier à la mairie 1 pour
répondre à votre question et du coup
elles ont monté le dossier obsédé il ya
déjà j'avais pas très bien très bien je
vois situe tout ça et après voilà
comment on se dit tiens on va réussir à
trouver 15 filles pour pour montrer
qu'il doit y avoir une base de copines
donc avec des et du coup ça va faire
certainement une ambiance qui peut être
très sympa dans cette équipe et moi je
pense que que les résultats de sur ce
dont peuvent être très très rapidement
hélène c'est compliqué de lancer une
section comme ça je pense qu'il faut
déjà
comme il disait assez de personnes
intéressées qui ont vraiment envie
et puis on part de rien du tout les
autorisations faut assez de comment dire
de motivation aussi il faut pas voir non
plus trop gros donc donc c'est plus les
personnes qui ont envie de participer
voilà qu'il faut trouver après je pense
que fur et à mesure ça va augmenter il y
aurait plus en plus de monde et on
n'aura plus ces questions du départ de
jean les filles sont assez jeunes
finalement les filles qui lance le
projet est ce que ça peut être un
inconvénient
peut-être dans la création d'une section
je pense que c'est le début donc que
comme elle débute déjà au moins un saut
sur deux pas de pas descendre on prend
que se maintenir puisque elle commencer
au plus bas niveau donc ça déjà au
niveau des objectifs c'est bien et puis
vaut mieux qu'elles soient jeunes parce
que si elle veut construire quelque
chose vous le faire sur plusieurs années
et il vaut mieux que ce soient des
sportives jeunes avec on vous a pas
entendu sur la question non c'est
l'excellence une très bonne initiative
pense que plus le maillage territorial
sera étendue plus ça facilitera l'accès
à la pratique sportive en particulier
que le handball féminin est plutôt
populaire en france donc profité de
l'appel surfer sur la dynamique pas
exactement il faut pas de façon enfin
séparé spatiale peuvent-elles doivent
penser elles deux elles veulent se
développer va falloir utiliser tous les
outils à leur disposition
c'est une bonne chose qu'elle s'intègre
à une section legend section masculine
qui remplace donc ça veut dire que j'ai
un bureau en place et et des gens
d'expérience sur lesquels se s'appuyer
pour se développer c'est sûr que quand
on manque d'expérience qu'on est assez
jeune c'est toujours toujours utile
d'avoir des référents vers qui se
tourner en cas de problème parce que
c'est vrai que c'est compliqué donc de
monter une section sportive de rien du
tout donc déjà long and wild buzz et
puis petit à petit ballet les joueuses
qui ont envie de rejoindre l'équipe font
grossir la section et on peut leur
souhaiter que que du succès pour les
années à venir pour les dirigeants qui
ont
ce projet ça que c'est un beau projet et
c'est une très bonne idée de naître à
l'initative et c'est quelque chose qui
comme dit jean mi ce qui va falloir
suivre sur sur le long terme
enfin sur un moyen terme déjà et pas se
projeter juste sur une ou deux saisons
et vraiment c'est quelque chose qui doit
et du coup le fait d'avoir des jeunes
des jeunes c'était très bien et ce avec
ça tu dois ça doit être
à l'objectif de se dire on l'ouvré il
faut que ça dure je vous c'est dur pour
nous alors on va passer maintenant au
programme de l'émission aujourd'hui nous
allons parler de dopage dans le sport
évinois nous avons notamment interrogé
le professeur alvarez de l'université de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines sur
le sujet nous allons également parler de
mercato des coaches et des dirigeants
dans les yvelines
mais avant de développer ces thèmes coup
de projecteur sur le dernier open de
france de golf
c'est l'homme en forme du moment il l'a
prouvé sur les greens du golf national
tommy fleetwood 26 ans 4e du dernier us
open a remporté la 101e édition de
l'open de france qui s'est déroulé du 30
juin au 2 juillet pour sa cinquième
apparition à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
la première depuis 2010 le fantasque
britannique totalise un score de moins
12 au total avec une carte de 66 soit
cinq coups sous le par le dimanche son
swing lui a permis de devenir le premier
anglais à remporter l'open de france
depuis 2006 2007 et la victoire de
graines storm
on écoute les réactions je pense que
c'était vraiment important de bien jouer
cette semaine
tout le monde a joué un très bon niveau
pour avoir un bon résultat
le parcours était très agréable et cela
m'a permis d'avoir un swing très
performant je pense que c'est un joueur
dont on entendra beaucoup parler dans le
futur magnifique
super joueur c'est une génération qui
arrive et ils sont super très très bien
du côté des tricolores on attendait le
meilleur français au classement mondial
alexander levy où l'imprévisible victor
dubuisson c'est finalement michael
lorenzo vera qui a réalisé la meilleure
performance des bleus a sur le parcours
de l'albatros avec un moins huit au
total
un score qui lui permet de terminer à
troisième du tournoi est de se qualifier
pour le british open une première pour
le basque de 32 ans qui avait du bon
golf du bonne attitude voilà tautou qui
a bien obtenu une belle partie en plus
ce dimanche avec lee westwood ça c'était
cool s'entend bien on joue bien et deux
donc c'est un bon moment ça fait bien
plaisir puisque vraiment le les gens
étaient des emplois depuis le début de
la semaine
chaque fois avec toujours des mots
gentils toujours voilà vraiment d un
monstre opera par lorenzo vera les
français ont globalement déçu le favori
des bleus donc alexander levy a terminé
à la 57e place avec un + 6 idem pour
victor dubuisson qui avait pourtant
terminé dans le top 5
il ya deux ans aucun français n'a
remporté le tournoi depuis 2011 c'était
thomas levet la question sur ce thème
est ce que c'est un inconvénient pour
les stars françaises de jouer en france
est ce que c'est un inconvénient vous
votez oui ou non on fait un petit duel
entre vous jean et yan yan vous qui avez
répondu oui j'ai répondu oui parce que
on s'aperçoit quand même un très haut
niveau que nous nous nos sportifs
français ont du mal à supporter la
pression alors que ce soit en golf en
tennis ou au tour de france ça fait très
longtemps qu'on n'a pas eu un vainqueur
de roland garros un vainqueur là comme
vous le disiez ça fait une prime en cinq
six ans maintenant pour pour le golf
là je pense que en effet soit il il
fallait un prof générationnel ans
françois ya un problème générationnel
mais j'y crois pas je pense que en fait
la vie en france et peut-être un peu
trop facile pour pour nos sportifs et et
donc du coup ils n'arrivent pas à ce
qu'on s'en va pas se concentrer mais
n'arrivent pas à obtenir les résultats
et qui peut-être désireraient où ils ont
pas l'implication suffisante pour
obtenir les résultats quand ils ont des
compétitions en france qui devraient
être des vrais objectifs pour eux et
pour pouvoir briller dans ces sports
dont on parle un peu moins une chaîne
une chaîne
comment nationales de sport dit son
espoir mineur puisque puisque ça parle
ça parle 90% de dessous de sueur sur
cette chaîne et donc voilà je pense que
pour pouvoir faire parler d'eux ils
devraient prendre les événements
sportifs à d'une autre d'une autre
manière avec une autre dimension pour
pouvoir ben resplendir on va dire sur
haut niveau au niveau national et qu'on
puisse parler de couette pour simplement
qu'on puisse parler d'eux et que et que
ces sports mineurs
ben est un peu plus de lumière de
lumière sur donc à nom de dommages mais
en effet je pense que pour eux c'est
compliqué mais c'est pas compliqué parce
qu'ils n'ont pas les moyens de le faire
je pense que c'est compliqué parce que
parce que c'est peut-être un peu trop
facile chez nous
genre ouais moi je suis dit que c'est
pour moi c'est le contraire
justement en france ils ont le public
derrière donc que ce soit au tennis ou
sow wolf puisque de sport qu'inciter
yann est justement et en ayant le public
derrière ils devraient se sentir petit
peu pousser des ailes et c'est là où
justement il peut performer et se
surpasse et surtout d'un disciplines
comme le golf où justement et on a vous
avez un petit peu de concentration et
d'adrénaline pour pouvoir pour permettre
de réaliser des de se surpasser et
réaliser des belles performances donc
moi je pense en plus que
il le souci est peut-être pas sur
simplement leur valeur sportive c'est
plus peut-être le sérieux aussi au
niveau de la compétition ici ici ici
d'après ce que vous avez dit si celle ci
est rien qui montrent que de sérieux au
golf sa part dans nos poches d'un
touriste pour certes mais principalement
au golf hellickson portée que ça peut
jouer selon lui demande voilà qui
demandait qu'un et norman de
concentration et d'application fallait
qu anderson qui a tort qui a raison
bon après je pense que ça dépend plus
des individus que que de raison en est
que de raisons géographiques après on
voit généralement quand on joue à
domicile on est plus à l'aise que quand
on va jouer à l'extérieur peut soi-même
dans le championnat de france 1 quand on
joue sur son propre stade où quand on va
dans un terrain qu'on connaît pas je
pense que connaître l'environnement
c'est un atout après c'est clair que ça
suffit pas pour faire la différence
puisque derrière il faut bien jouer mais
je pense que plus on contre son
environnement plus et l'environnement
est propice à la performance donc en
général je pense pas que ce soit une
bonne excuse de dire qu on performe mal
parce que j'ai trop de pression à
domicile etc
je pense que c'est le parcours ils le
connaissent il sait pas la première fois
qu'ils viennent de jouer sur les
conditions changent en fonction de la
météo et ils sont ball faire il vous
prend la playstation sur un peu paralysé
il ya peut-être aussi d'être devant son
public justement une grosse pression les
années qui viennent la famille également
qu'ils savaient nous paralyser finale
guy lycée il ya deux effet c'est soit ça
vous le galvanise soit ça vous paralyse
bas maintenant il faut il faut savoir
travailler avec mes - voilà ça fait
quand même des années des années que
c'est d'espacé des professionnels
normalement moi je vois là je parle
vraiment du principe que ça devrait les
galvaniser et non pas les tétaniser
c'est clair ok ça peut peut-être un peu
les jeux d'hier les impressionner mais
ils n'ont pas non plus leur public juste
là comme dans un match de foot ou comme
sur un ring
ils sont pas juste les gens sont pas
juste là ils sont loin ici quand ils
sont en train de jouer ils sont au
milieu de leur espace
je pense pas qu'il s'en qui pense en
premier au public ou non ils ont pour
moi qu'une chose à penser c'est le
terrain où ils sont le le coût à
[Musique]
un mètre et repère les repères sont les
repères ne sont pas complètement modifié
quand vous avez des spectateurs qui sont
à 20 ou 30 mètres
et en effet quand enfin aux joies bien
quand on est dans une compétition moi
quand je suis dans un match de vitesse
qui est 5000 personnes ou qui est
vingt personnes au bord de la piste eh
bien il ya qu un seul truc auquel je
pense c'est l'adversaire avec contre
lesquels je cours j'ai complètement
abstraction de ce qui se passe autour
maintenant une fois que le match il est
fini c'est nettement plus sympa de
gagner un match devant 5000 personnes et
du coup parce que les encouragements
j'ai eu la chance de pouvoir faire des
démonstrations ou des deux une
compétition à saint quentin où il y
avait deux mille cinq cents personnes un
vélodrome c'est j'ai compris à ce moment
là la raison pour lesquelles il n'y
avait pas de pression supplémentaire est
pas dupe mais non pas du tout pas du
tout ça quant à partir du moment où on
rentre sur le sur le ring ou sur la
piste sur le fameux sur le saumon
vélodrome et je pense plus qu'à mes
adversaires est la tactique que j'ai mis
en place pour pour cette compétition
le reste le reste c'est ça c'est valable
c'est valable dans tous les sports bien
sûr dès qu'on rende sur l'air de je sais
ce que c'est ni plus ni moins cher de
jeu visite parlait parce que sans la
mise de remise dès qu'on rentre en moins
souvent je vous dis donc je prends au
niveau des joueurs je leur dis qu'ils
soient dans une bulle puis ce qui se
passe à l'extérieur il faut il faut
qu'il faut qu'il soit hermétique à ça et
voilà et c'est comme ça qu'on peut être
on peut performer
lorsqu on fait abstraction de tout ce
qui est auto et finalement quand on
regardait les résultats l'open de france
ceux qui ont performé lorenzo vera qui
termine troisième ce sont pas forcément
ceux qu'on attendait du coup au début de
la compétition la tombe et victor
dubuisson alexander levy
finalement c'est lorenzo vera qui qui
finit troisième
est ce que ça peut jouer également sur
peut-être la pression peut-être plus sur
les gros sportif que sur les sportifs un
peu plus à neuilly c'est sûr pourquoi ça
c'est certain
les ce qu'on attend comme comme vous
avez dit ce qu'on attend au virage entre
guillemets
ils ont un peu plus de pression a déjà
un peu moins mais louper parce que alors
que l'outsider que personne n'attend ils
se retrouvent il fait le produit avec
les troisièmes ben là c'est une super
performance
peut-être aussi une question de je me
repose un peu sur mes lauriers parce que
je sais que je suis un peu en gd à qui
donc il ya aussi ce risque-là donc être
peut-être moins concentrés ou se laisser
un peu distraire et finalement 1
et là je vous laisse sur les ventes sur
ce type de choses que je vais intervenir
souvent ce qu'on attend des
sollicitations différentes qui font que
ça les détournent de leurs de leurs
extra sportifs d esprit sportif et
journalistique dépression avec des
partenaires qui peuvent être présents et
donc du coup on récupère un petit peu
moins
et donc voilà en effet ce sont toutes
ces choses là quand on est à domicile
qui ne va pas rencontrer quand on est
allé quand on est dans d'autres
dans d'autres lieux et c'est vrai que du
coup ça peut avoir l'impact sur ce qu'on
attend et et celui que l'on n'attend pas
beaucoup moins sollicité
eh bien il va continuer va rester et il
va être dans son élément
eh bien il va pouvoir performer parce
que là il aura une et lui l'oreille ses
repères mais il n'aura pas été parasités
au tour par les journalistes par exemple
avec la personne derrière dernière
question ça marche peut-être plus dans
la passion peut-être plus grande dans
les sports individuels conneries sports
collectifs on voit que en tennis c'est
compliqué pour les français à roland
garros par exemple
gaël monfils richard gasquet jo wilfried
tsonga n'arrive toujours pas à gagner
roland garros alors qu'ils sont devant
leur public et qui sont bien classés au
niveau 1 niveau mondial par contre dans
les sports plus collectif comme l'équipe
de france de football
en 98 tout lors de l'euro 2006 2016 là
par contre la france arrivait à
performer je ne sais pas si c'est plus
facile dans les sports collectifs et
j'ai l'exemple le plus flagrant c'est le
psg qui essaient d'arriver en finale de
ligue des champions qui arrive toujours
pas donc demeurer sports collectifs et
des déceptions des pressions médiatiques
autour
je pense que tout ça ça illustre aussi
l'aspect psychologique de la performance
sportive
c'est pas juste une question de taper là
bas il ya un état d'esprit et caetera et
c'est vrai que petit à petit on voit on
voit de plus en plus des préparateurs
psychologiques fin des essais des
préparateurs mentaux dans le sport qui
arrive à faire différent chez certaines
personnes après ça dépend des personnes
et des personnes qui ont un caractère
très indépendant pour qui ça sera aucun
impact ça arrive facilement à se
concentrer y en a d'autres qui sont plus
plus susceptibles à à la pression je
pense que je suis pas sûr que ce soit
vraiment différent c'est vrai qu'en
sport un sport collectif c'est plus
difficile de pointer un joueur du doigt
encore que les journalistes arrivent
très bien à le faire on voit pas en pl
équipes qui donnent des notes à tout le
monde que sur un sport collectif en
sport individuel on peut toujours avoir
un esprit une vision critique de la
performance de chacun et puis l'évaluer
je pense pas que ce soit une grosse
différence non c'est par des
sacrificateurs jeu mais la cloche il
faut avant son émission d elias
dujarrier l'athlétisme organisée as
ni et les résultats des français avait
été très très très sûr pas très brillant
voilà c'était juste là dessus que j'ai
juste la petite phrase pour conclure la
thématique résultat on continue à parler
de golf dans notre coup de projecteur
jingle dans notre coup de projecteur
reste donc à l'open de france de golf
vous l'avez peut-être remarqué si vous
êtes passés sur les greens de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la compétition
a pris un nouvel essor cette année
nouvelle organisation nouveau parking
rénovation de l'hôtel des joueurs de
renom tout cela grâce à l'eau aux
nouveaux sponsors à chennai
l'entreprise qui investit dans le rendez
vous saint quentinois et la dotation est
passé de cette mesure à 7 million de
dollars le double par rapport à 2016
on écoute le président de la fédération
française de golf jean-charles nous
sommes-nous fédération ravi de cette
évolution
nous sommes ravis de cette montée en
puissance de notre open national
et puis on croise les doigts pour ça se
poursuit dans le tous les temps du terme
c'est un superbe événement voilà on a la
chance de faire partie des plus gros
tournois européens
donc pour nous français on est très
heureux d'avoir un tournoi comme ça le
tournoi également intégrer les rolex
séries ce l'équivalent des masters 1000
au tennis le seul regret reste le
plateau de joueurs seulement un top 10
ces déplacés pour l'événement avec
l'espagnol jeunes ram la question sur ce
thème est-ce qu'il faut encore attendre
avant d'analyser l'impact du nouveau
sponsor sur l'open de france
oui ou non est-ce qu'il faut encore
attendre oui oui vous êtes unanime
allez viens du jard y est je suis bien
sûr ils viennent d'arriver on en a quand
on a commencé à en parler en début
d'année ceux de mémoire donc voilà faut
faut laisser le temps faut que ça prenne
un sportif quel que soit son niveau 1
quelle que soit
ouais son niveau le programme on le fait
bien en amont tout début de saison donc
je ne sais pas à quel moment commence sa
saison de golf mais voilà peut-être que
les gars la signature avec à chênée
s'est effectuée au mois de janvier
voilà j'en la saison est-ce que la
saison de golf n'est pas commencé un peu
plus tard et donc du coup les gens
avaient déjà fait leur programme pour
toute la saison et peut-être que les dix
meilleurs mondiaux sont sur une phase de
travail qui est complètement différente
et qu'il ne promettait pas de pouvoir se
déplacer pour faire un tournoi de cette
de cette importance on voit bien que
le suisse roger federer n'est pas venu à
roland garros cette année pour des pour
des raisons quand on arrive à un certain
niveau il faut cibler ses objectifs et
donc gallas peut-être que l'open de
france est arrivé avec son prize money
un petit peu trop tard bah tant mieux
pour dans un peut être plus grand encore
l'année prochaine j'ai mis ça le sera
celle sera l'année prochaine bien sûr
jean miss vous qui êtes un passionné de
golf
on sent quelques le rendez vous quand
même elle est plus professionnel si on
regarde bien nouveau parking nouveau
centre de presse nouvel hôtel les
joueurs également se déplacer en parle
du coût de cet open de france n'était
pas forcément le cas dans le passé
voilà est-ce qu'on sent qu'il ya un
professionnalisme qui s'est mis en place
cette année
il ya surtout une grande médiatisation
qui commence à se resserrer autour du
golf c'est mon oreillette il y est tombé
a les jambes qui la médiatisation de ce
retour du golf
déjà parce que si on a doublé s'ils ont
doublé le montant du partenariat fait du
sponsoring plus tôt et en plus on voit
aussi venir l'année prochaine
ryder cup qui va qui va aller dans la
continuité de tout le travail de
publicitaire et technique et sportif et
toute l'évolution de ce site
et quand même fait avant tout pour 2018
et là la compétition suprême
donc heureusement que lily à ce cette
hausse de niveau en niveau 2 au niveau
organisation ça n'allait pas il ya bien
sûr parce que parce que sinon vous avez
été à la ryder cup
il ya une année dernière et vous avez
bien vu l'ampleur du phénomène jeu
je pense que voilà le fait d'augmenter
un peu le niveau la capacité et ses
organisations de parents non non bien
sûr
et le tour de france dans le tour de
france vous croyez qu'il n'est organisée
depuis depuis l'année dernière on a on
n'arrive pas à des grosses machines
aussi grosse machine du jour au
lendemain voilà voilà le tournoi par
contre a failli faire et quand des
ressorts voilà avoir une baisse de
revenus avec alstom qui avait lâché
l'open de france l'année dernière en
plein tournoi il avait annoncé aux
organisateurs finalement on ne signe pas
pour l'année prochaine donc à chênée
finalement c'est une bouffée d'oxygène
et c'est même mieux finalement que que
alstom
sur les dernières éditions il récupère
un des ressources supplémentaires donc
deux utilisés correctement après c'est
au final comme vous utilisiez c'est en
janvier que ça a été annoncé donc c'est
finalement ces faits kaksee moins que ça
peut impacter la l'organisation du
tournoi un trouveur de cette envergure
six mois c'est court
je pense que déjà c'est une belle
réussite vis-à-vis des résultats qu'ils
ont obtenus arriver à attirer que des
têtes de série malgré qu'il n'y en ait
pas autant qu'on pourrait l'espérer
peut-être aussi que c'est les gens
attendent de voir est ce que ce que
c'est vraiment mieux est ce que c'est
moins bien je pense que les golfeurs ont
pas ont pas envie de prendre le risque
d'arriver dans un tournoi nouveau ne pas
connaître ce qui va se passer comment
s'organiser avec le doute de ce que ce
soit un échec soit un flop
donc là c'est comme ils ont réussi cette
année ça va faire du bruit ça va faire
des bonnes des bons retours et ça va
sûrement attirer plus de monde
après c'est sûr que ça demande du temps
si on fait un comparatif avec avec moi
ce que je connais sur le football mais
quand on regarde tout faux pas mais à
quand une universitaire aux états unis
quand ils changent d'entraîneur en chef
il change toute l'organisation de
l'équipe le recrutement tout ça et c'est
vrai qu'il faut attendre parfois deux
trois quatre saisons avant de voir
l'équipe arriver arrive au sommet et
c'est vrai qu'une fois qu'on est devant
le fait accompli a l'impression c'était
facile mais il faut pas oublier que
derrière il ya trois quatre ans de
galère et du beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
de travail donc qu'on ne s'est pas
construite en un jour et je pense que
les résultats qu'ils ont réussi à
produire en six mois sont très
encourageants pour l'avenir
donc on peut que leur souhaiter de
poursuivre sur cette lancée et là une
petite déception quand même c'est au
niveau du public
il y avait entre 40000 et 50000
personnes à peu près sur les greens de
saint quentin en yvelines
voilà on attendait peut-être un petit
peu plus est ce qu'il y aura un effet
peut-être ryder cup l'année prochaine
pour que son apprennent encore plus en
plus si sûr comme
frédéric de toute façon au fur et à
mesure des saisons des années ça va
attirer du monde je pense que voilà ils
vont savoir exploiter les nouvelles
ressources qu'ils ont et ça se fait pas
en un jour ça se fait pendant une saison
non plus c'est comme toute chose qui
commence au toute chose qui en vraiment
en évolution tant que c'est pas on n'est
pas arrivé au summum de l'organisation
et à quelque chose d'équivalent à ce qui
se fait ailleurs
voilà ça va se mettre en place petit à
petit les gens vont s'intéresser mais
j'allais vous avez marqué communication
parce qu aux limites quand même ça on
est sûr saint-quentin-en-yvelines encore
une fois un événement important et bien
je n'avais pas entendu parler je n'ai
pas entendu parler des dates voilà donc
quand même des panneaux partout dans
saint quentin en yvelines et c'est moi
quand je viens je vais au vélodrome on y
fait je fais du vélo je fais très
attention aux voitures qu'il peut y
avoir c'est bon à savoir il ya tout
juste finir quand même rapidement oui on
sent qu'à une belle dynamique à l'image
du président
[Musique]
je vais passer au prochain thème genre
désolé de paron dire là dessus
deuxième coup de projecteur nous allons
parler du mercato yvelinois il va vous
concerner un jour ni ce qui risque
d'être agité le départ ce qui risque
d'agiter le département cet été y aura
notamment du changement attrape mustapha
larfaoui président de l'étoile sportive
de trappes depuis 14 ans va quitter le
club sous son impulsion le club de
football a dépassé ces dernières années
les mille licenciés le dirigeant a
également créé une section féminine et
une académie scolaire pour aider les
jeunes joueurs on écoute les raisons qui
ont poussé appartient moi si j'ai
souhaité m'arrêter cette année c'est
parce que j'ai toujours eue c'était
l'idée qu' il fallait jamais assez très
longtemps ou surtout trop longtemps
quand on est dans un tourbillon comme
celui que je vis professionnels
associatifs et personnel on se rend
compte que les choses vont vite ce que
j'aime et en même temps il ya des choses
qu'on risquerait de laisser passer et
je voudrais surtout pas passer à côté de
certaines choses importantes alors
mustapha sera remplacé par abdel
guessoum qui vient d'être nommé à
l'issue de la saison mustapha larfaoui
restera tout de même président d'honneur
mais le cas de mustapha n'est pas un cas
isolé ça va bouger dans les yvelines
avec son taillefer coach de l'équipe
seniors de handball de versailles va
également quitter le club vous genlis
vous allez également quitté le club de
plaisir malgré une très belle saison
avec une montée en fédérale 2 et un
parcours historique en championnat de
france
la question sur ce thème peut-on
construire dans la durée dans les clubs
amateurs
oui ou non peut-on construire dans la
durée dans les clubs amateurs
vous êtes partagés gens on va on attend
de voir peuvent être partagées vaut
aussi à l'or fin petite ville entre vous
et l'aisne et férec paraît que vous
commencez moi je pense que oui et non ça
dépend un peu du contexte
moi si je prends mon cas particulier ça
fait dix ans que chez les templiers
je suis un peu un enfant du club donc
c'est vrai que la continuité c'est moi
qui l'incarné c'est vrai que c'est plus
peut-être plus facile pour moi j'ai
moins de risque par rapport au résultat
et je pense que les gens mettront
difficilement en doute mon intérêt de
faire monter le club au plus haut niveau
maintenant pour quelqu'un qui vient de
l'extérieur qui est pas du club je veux
dire pour les dirigeants et il vient
pour une ou deux saisons il représente
pas forcément l'histoire du club où
quelque chose de vraiment de vraiment
profond et qui est un qui incarne
vraiment le club
donc c'est peut-être plus facile de se
séparer de quelqu'un qui vient de
l'extérieur quelqu'un qui vient de la
structure elle même
je pense qu'il faut faire un peu la
différence après ce qu'on peut et est-ce
qu'on peut pas c'est vrai que ça dépend
aussi la situation financière de la
structure les associations dépendent
beaucoup des des financements publics on
a du mal
quel que soit le sport de toute façon en
mai peut-être le football au plus haut
niveau à trouver des partenaires des
partenaires prime est privé donc dès
qu'il ya une coupe de subventions au
niveau public
les ressources sont réduits il faut
prendre des décisions et c'est vrai que
les premières parties sont les derniers
généralement et c'est vrai que de ce
point de vue là c'est quand même
compliqué développer une association
amateur
quel que soit le niveau quel que soit
l'endroit c'est pas propre aux hiboux
non plus je suis d'accord avec ce qui
vient du nom mais je suis d'accord avec
ce qu'il dit c'est pas une question de
est ce que on peut et est-ce qu'on peut
pas c'est vraiment pas ça c'est une
question de motivation d'implication il
est évident que c'est quelqu'un de
l'intérieur ça voilà il ya quand même
plus de il restera sûrement plus
longtemps on aura plus d'implication
n'aura plus le souhait de faire grandir
on peut avoir ça aussi de quelqu'un de
l'extérieur mais c'est vrai que c'est
quelqu'un de l'extérieur vient
je pense qu'il faut qu'ils viennent
vraiment pour une durée assez longue de
vrais objectifs et qui se met ouais
vraiment de vrais objectifs on peut pas
être là rester deux ou trois saisons et
partir c'est pas mon avis c'est pas
assez
yann j'ai une question ces gens me se
tue pas rond pas de dire si sujet jr
cateau et alexandre taillefer et aussi
pour l'instant pas d'informations sur
les 100 d'accord ça va donc du coup je
me serais restera chroniqueur puisqu'ils
restent sur secteur parce que signé en
août alpha mustapha ne reviendra pas
puisque lui il sera plus président
d'honneur du président d'honneur donc
non il ya un gros débat pour revenir au
débat
bon ya pas de débat d'en bas après oui
voilà tout
tout a été tout a été dit par par mes
confrères ont la durée de vie d'un coach
haut niveau amateur serait de deux ans
parce que s'il est bon il est sollicité
par par d'autres avec plus de moyens
donc sa main tout le monde cherche aussi
des gens qui peut avoir des bonnes idées
et puis ben s'il est mauvais il faut pas
le conserver trop longtemps parce que
ben sinon on va on va faire tomber
toutes les équipes tout doit toutes les
équipes parce que faut bien savoir c'est
que à très haut niveau un coach je ne
s'occupe que d'une équipe mais plus on
descend dans la hiérarchie plus un coach
et multi multi casquettes et donc il ne
s'occupe pas que de l'équipe première il
s'occupe d'eux aussi de la formation etc
voilà il faut pas il faut essayer faut
être assez réactif et et puis je pense
que voilà quand quand les gens sont les
gens sont bons ils se font aussi
rapidement récupéré pour aller voir rien
d'accord personne est ce que vous
trouvez que le départ de jean louis
s'est justifié voilà dans le cas d'
alexandre taillefer ça pouvait se
comprendre là l'équipe de versailles
était mal positionné au classement le
club avait des résultats décevant mais
dans le cas de plaisir jean miss avait
des bons résultats il monte en fédérale
2 il avait un parcours historique dans
le championnat de france avec un quart
de finale
est ce que vous comprenez ce choix est
ce que ce n'est pas là le problème du
sport amateur finalement de se séparer
de quelqu'un qui a des bons résultats
pour peut-être prendre quelqu'un d'autre
qui ne fera pas les bons résultats après
pas pouvoir préparer l'avenir en
fédérale 2 but après ce que je le
comprends non puisque d'un point de vue
purement sportif a aucune raison de se
séparer quand on gagne je veux dire
c'est à moins que à moins que
l'entraîneur décidé de lui-même de
partir parce qu'il a une meilleure offre
et a aucune raison de se séparer de
quelqu'un après ça dépend aussi du de la
vision du club et du leadership c'est
vrai que souvent quand ya un manque de
vision à long terme on a plus tendance à
changer les entraîneurs que les joueurs
parce que c'est beaucoup plus facile de
trouver un nouveau coach peut trouver
des nouveaux joueurs on a près un autre
souci qui oscille sur la structure
amateur c'est comme on est amateur on
dépend de notre boulot et c'est vrai
qu'il ya des mutations au niveau du
travail pour moi je sais qu à l encours
on est déjà en train de regarder les
coaching staff pour différentes sections
année prochaine et je suis encore en
attente de réponses de certains qui sont
qui peuvent pas me dire aujourd'hui
parce que ils ont peut-être des offres
de façon peut-être des possibilités
d'être mutés dans d'autres régions est
bas mais le point de vue pratique l'on
va pas garder on peut pas garder
quelqu'un qui pour des raisons
professionnelles doit partir dans une
autre région donc ça aussi c'est un
autre défi du du monde amateur qui rend
la construction d'un club le
développement du club encore plus encore
plus difficile donc non c'est vrai que
dans lequel jean miss je comprends pas
particulièrement après je suis pas dans
ce club et il a peut-être des raisons
que j'ignore aussi genre on vous a pas
entendu sur la question être concernés
je suis concerné tout à fait donc après
mois pour moi deux ans et je pense que
c'est plutôt 3
au niveau de la durée de vie d'un
entraîneur dans les vélos baptiste voilà
c'est dit moi je pense que c'est plutôt
trois dans la mesure où il faut quand
même un certain temps pour mettre un jeu
en place en parlant du rugby puisque
c'est du rugby combat là il faut un
certain temps pour mettre le jeu en
place et que la mayonnaise prenne
laon moi j'étais venu il ya deux saisons
pour pour la montée du club
on est monté en deux saisons maintenant
les choix des clubs les choix des
présidents ont fait du président et du
bureau
mais il faut toujours accepter on sait
pertinemment que moi en tant
qu'entraîneur je suis pas un enfant du
club mon club formateur c'est c'était le
sud-ouest cc marmande donc je suis pas
du tout les ex de plaisir donc forcément
je suis le passage ensuite après la
politique du club
mais elle leur appartient moi je ne peux
que que la respecter si les choses sont
faites de façon convenable et
respectueuse vis-à-vis des entraîneurs
mais sa rentrée dans les détails
moi ce qui me choque un petit peu je lui
ai déjà vécu dans notre club c'est un
petit peu dommage parce que le jeu avait
pris quelques importe la manière mais le
jeu a pris et les résultats étaient là
c'est la plus belle saison de l'histoire
du club les je pense qu'il y avait un
élan qui était intéressant de continuer
à cultiver
parce qu'il y avait la montée en
fédérale 2 ce que je comprends pas au
niveau la politique du club c'est que
mais ils sont déjà montée en fédérale 2
ils ont fait des erreurs qui finalement
apparemment le rencontrer servi
tellement servi puisque là eh bien on
casse l'élan d'un groupe qui est quand
même en place où on a mis deux saisons
pour mettre quelque chose de bien en
place qui a porté ses fruits la preuve
en est les résultats et puis là on va
casser quelque chose avec des nouveaux
entraîneurs qui forcément vont changer
puisque on amène toujours hélas et
d'entraîneurs qui parle on avait
toujours sa patte personnelle de keur re
falloir du temps pour remettre les
choses en place mais le times ne pas
l'avoir parce que fédérale 2 forcément
les matchs vont être durs tous les
dimanches
et là je pense que c'est une erreur du
club mais après ça m'appartient pas à
moi comme j'ai dit moi je suis passé je
suis maintenant surgissent
m avec un nouveau projet qui matin et
auxquels je vais tout mettre en oeuvre
pour essayer d'y arriver
bon on continuera vous suivez vous avoir
sur ce plateau c'est un réel plaisir
encore jamais rien à dire il ya six
salariés désolé pour l'avancée dans
l'émission on va passer maintenant notre
rubrique débats
notre débat concerne aujourd'hui un
vaste sujet dans le monde du sport le
dopage dans les yvelines il y aurait
plus d'une vingtaine de cas recensés au
niveau judiciaire un phénomène qui
pourrait toucher des milliers de
personnes dans le département dans le
plus grand anonymat et sans vrai
contrôle mais quels sont les sports les
plus touchés nous avons posé la question
au professeur jean-claude alvarez chef
de service au laboratoire de
pharmacologie et de toxicologie à
l'hôpital de garches certains sports
sont plus ciblées que d'autres nous
rires on a peut-être eu un petit peu
plus d'affaires dans le cyclisme
probablement mais peut-être que c'est le
hasard j'en sais rien mais c'est clair
que oui dans ses clips
le chic nice mais aujourd'hui on a une à
quelque chose qui est peut-être plus
inquiétant c'est le dopage
non pas dans un cadre de compétition
mais dans les salles de musculation s'y
recoller prend les gens prennent des
dopants pour faire leur bus culation pas
forcément dans un cadre compétition pour
développer leur masse musculaire
la question sur ce thème est-ce que ce
dopage niveau amateur vous surprend oui
ou non non oui à un petit duel gens
contre ferrer qu'anderson fabricant des
fameux commencé c'est pas tellement qui
me surprend c'est plus que je le
regrette parce que aucun intérêt il ya
aucun intérêt à risquer sa santé quand
on n'est pas impliqué quand c'est pas
son boulot mais même quand c'est son
boulot même quand c'est le plus haut
niveau il n'y a aucune justification
possible pour le faire après ces
épreuves au fin fond vous rappeler que
c'est des pros le problème s'était
produit dangereux pour la santé à la
basse et des médicaments et comme tout
médicament il ya aussi des effets
secondaires et le problème c'est que les
gens sont pas assez sensibilisés sur la
nature des produits leur fonctionnement
leurs effets sur le corps on a un peu
tendance souvent à diaboliser le dopage
à l'excès et je pense que cet excès
desserre un peu le la cause dans ce sens
où les gens se rendent compte qu'on est
dans l'exagération et du coup il doute
de tout ce qu'il ya derrière
mais le risque est réel par exemple
quand on prend les stéroïdes
anabolisants le gros problème c'est pour
le foie ça le foie d'oie détoxifier bas
toutes ces substances qui sont pas
censés être là et on peut se retrouver
avec des cas d'hépatites des quatre
pistes dans fois le problème c'est que
le fois ça se remplace pas c'est une
fois une fois qu'on doit couper la santé
elle coupe aussi donc c'est vrai que
c'est non c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas
ça surprend c'est que je vois pas le
raisonnement qui peut y avoir derrière
et c'est vrai qu'un des soucis du dopage
c'est qu'on se rend compte que le plus
grand nombre de cas passe au niveau
amateur c'est dans les petits niveaux il
ya plus de gens qui puissent se dopent
alors ça ça n'a pas de sens moi mon sens
les gens pour vous donner quelques
chiffres entre 5 et 15% des sportifs
ceux d'après dans les yvelines
neuf cent mille à 2,7 millions de
personnes en france
enfin vous surprendre ces chiffres alors
bon ça me surprend pas du tout parce
qu'il ya très très longtemps que
que les sportifs se dope aprilia dopage
de dopage ces deux-là ce niveau amateur
las au niveau mais il y avait un
deux formes de dopage rendant le dopage
les sportifs qui ce qu'on appelle la
fumette ceux qui fument n'est joué ça ça
rame dans le dopage est alors 6 à
ramener dans les chiffres
forcément je peux vous dire que dans
tous les sports il y en a un paquet
malheureusement c'est non mais c'est la
jeunesse qui veut ça il y en a beaucoup
moi j'en vois dans le rugby notamment
puisque je me souviens de rugby donc j y
en a quand même pas mal mais après moi
ça me surprend pas dans la mesure où il
ya je dis que c'est à l'automne que ça
existe
parce que qui dit dopage dit performance
qui dit performance des résultats et qui
dit résultats dit argent et même au
niveau amateur est là bon je tape pas
sur le cyclisme mais pour moi c'est le
professeur qu'il a dit mais moi je sais
que même dans des petites courses de
c'est notamment là le plus dangereux le
plus dangereux
même chez les jeunes gens en exemple la
qui vient de tomber à gagner quelques
jours un jeune cycliste de 14 ans a été
contrôlé positif à un anabolisant lors
d'un test antidopage donc le 28 juin
dernier en italie c'est le sportif le
plus jeune jamais contrôler une réaction
aussi bien considéré c'est pas des
tricheurs voilà donc c'est ça
petite course mais pourquoi parce qu'ils
gagnent de l'argent je gagne de l'argent
donc ça me surprend absolument pas il ya
très longtemps que ça existe oui mais
plus grosse saison des plus grosses
saisons à l'époque c'était en francs
bien c'était un mois de salaire sur une
sur l'année voilà donc calmés donnes tu
peux l'avouer devant vous a été
sollicitée ou iliad entend je jase et on
ne m'a jamais proposé quoi que ce soit
il sait qui c'est vraiment une question
de reims où je vous promets c'est le
jour le curé propose un outil on ne m'a
jamais proposé jamais rien proposé
vraiment léger est ce que vous l'avez vu
vous de vos partenaires vous avez déjà
vu un homme par contre par contre parce
que j'ai déjà entendu des mecs dire
ouais moi je charge
voilà mon après il ya des ya des
légendes un aussi des gars qui à niveau
amateur testent les produits pour les
tester des produits pour les équipes
professionnelles
voilà donc bon
qu'est ce que vous voulez c'est comme ça
maintenant moi je sais enfin j'ai
toujours eu et j'ai toujours eu la
fierté de me dire j'ai gagné cette
course là est peut-être qu'il est dopé
dans le peloton mais je suis quand même
devant voilà c'est pas c'est pas grave
je trouve ça dommage surtout au niveau
amateur moi ma promo ce que jamais
puisque j'ai ma pensée profonde c'était
que s'il fallait se doper pour monter
d'un niveau quand on était déjà amateur
qu'est ce qu'on allait faire content
quand on serait professionnels
il ya un moment où on m6 enfin s'il faut
se doper pour devenir professionnel
ben quand tu seras pro tu gagneras
jamais une course donc et l'objectif
d'un sportif c'est pas juste de
participer c'est de gagner quel que soit
le niveau auquel il va il va courir donc
donc je trouve ça un petit peu dommage
et surtout en plus pour reprendre que
faudrait il disait c'est que derrière ça
mais le le doute sur toutes les
performances que l'on peut que l'on peut
voir et
et actuellement je vis une progression
parce que ça fait ça fait trois saisons
que je m'entraîne très sérieusement sur
sur les éléments et sa demande bien sûr
mais comme comme je les ai toujours fait
depuis depuis l'âge de 14 15 ans que je
fais du vélo
j'y vois là est donc bien là depuis
trois ans c'est vrai que je mets une
application et un entraînement différent
et je commence en percevoir les fruits
etc c'est quand même assez
impressionnant le gain en terme de temps
sur sur les chronos et donc donc je
pense qu'aujourd'hui il ya des gens qui
parlent de moi en disant ben je vois
chargé en moi j'invite toutes ces
personnes
il va mater à ce que vous avez des
contrôles mais rien du tout pas du tout
et je suis prêt moi allez allez me faire
contrôler à la date que n'importe qui
choisit parce que on peut aussi arriver
sur les compétitions en étant propre et
avoir chargé pendant pendant plusieurs
mois à l'entraînement à faire un
contrôle et si jamais par contre je paye
le contrôle mais si jamais le contrôle
est négatif il sera à la charge de la
personne qui m'a frappé de l'argent
après il n'y a pas spécialement pour les
compétitions il l'a dit d'ailleurs un
professeur on voit dans les salles de
musculation fable ii mais simplement
pour l'aspect physique des gens qui vont
qui vont prendre des produits
et oui il divo kiwi avait à travers
lesquelles ils vont s'allumer le corps
simplement pour pouvoir prendre de la
masse musculaire et pouvoir faire le
beau après ce qu'ils savent qu'ils
seront volés puis physique les espèces
de reconnaissance de son physique de
culte du corps de l'apparence etc
on cherche à exister peut-être à travers
le sport oui oui puis non à travers ce
qu'on se pince con
on se montre en fait à travers les
marins donc
voilà impressionné des fouaces et puis
quand comme on le disait aussi c'est ça
commence avec des petites choses et je
pense qu'on peut glisser vite sur des
choses vraiment encore plus nos cils
sans même s'en rendre compte ce que
disent les gens et sans objectif arriver
à fumer un joint je pense qu'avant de
fumer un joint il faut d'abord faire une
cigarette est donc bien pour le dopage
c'est pareil avant de prendre des
stéroïdes anabolisants ou des sols c'est
pas pour sur le joaillier je fais moins
festive c'est qu'on serait comme produit
dopant mais partout mais médée des
hormones de croissance comme ça eh bien
ils prennent d'autres produits la
tarière bref voilà il ya des étapes et
après on arrive à des choses qui donnent
beaucoup plus bordélique période des
petites du real et une semaine pour
mettre en forme un peu comme les régimes
en fait finalement c'est je fais ma
petite cure ceci même petite cure cela
c'est ça et après on tombe sur des trucs
et des curés alors qu'il n'y a pas
besoin de faire ça
grâce à cette petite cure justement jan
voilà je suis désolé vous coupez il faut
avancer dans l'émission voilà désolé ça
tombe sur vous aujourd'hui
voilà il faut acheter ses produits
quelque part et c'est souvent sur
internet comme nous l'expliquent le
professeur jean-claude alvarez c'est
très facile d'accès des cantons
l'utilisons c'est vraiment parce qu'on
prend on al'impression comprendre la
baule des normes de la testostérone et
en fait quand on fait l'analyse je peux
vous garantir que
au moins la moitié des cas on n'a pas la
molécule dedans et quand on a la bonne
molécule affreux n'a pas le bon dosage
c'est à dire que c'est du 10 mg l
en fait non c'est du vin du 30 du 40 du
50 ou du 5 ou du 1
ça dépend des fois souvent c'est
inférieur c'est à dire que ça fait moins
d'effet que prévu forcément on fait des
économies
mais voilà donc vous prenez des produits
vous pensé prendre des produits
anabolisants
d'abord vous ne prenez pas le bon n'est
pas le bon dosage nous risquent bien
entendu est ce que quand on connaît pas
le dosage on peut faire une overdose
s'effacer des goodies et frédéric tout à
l'heure voilà vous en parliez de
d'internet de ses soucis on va dire de
dos qu'on peut prendre ou ne pas prendre
comment on fait pour lutter contre
contre ce phénomène
fo est impossible quasiment de champion
produits sur internet et de le réguler
c'est impossible il ya que l'éducation
qui peut il faut sensibiliser les gens
le gros problème même rien que sur les
suppléments alimentaires c'est
l'adultération des produits quand on
sait pas d'où ça vient et qu'on n'est
pas sûr de la provenance des cdc des
produits illicites donc de toute façon
il ya très peu de contrôles qui sont
fait dessus comme disait le professeur
on commet d'intruction tête on sait pas
ce qu'il ya dedans et donc c'est vrai
que le en fait le plus gros risque sur
ces pratiques là c'est pas tellement les
risques du dopage auquel cesser de
prendre un produit dont qui est
dangereux pour la santé parce qu'il a
été modifié parce qu'il est sale parce
qu'il est pas propre même façon vous
faut pas utiliser de deux fois de suite
la même seringue
enfin ce genre de problème la con avec
eux sur les avec les toxicomanes etc
c'est vrai que ces problèmes on n'en
parle pas assez on a toujours à temps
c'est à dire le le dopage c'est pas bien
faut pas faire point faut leur expliquer
aux gens comment ça fonctionne pourquoi
c'est pas bien et jusqu'où jusqu'où ces
dangereux et puis après les gens sont
assez grands faut qu'ils fassent faut
qu'il fasse la part des choses il ya
seulement eu aux huiles contrôle
antidopage dans toute la france en 2013
onze mille dans toute la france après
les dans le sport amateur
moteur maintien c'est les moyens pour
mais aussi dans la lutte contre le
dopage c'est vrai que quand on a peu
quand on a peu de ressources parce qu'il
ya vraiment beaucoup de monde à
contrôler on aura peut-être un contrôle
ça coûte environ 100 euros
on aurait peut-être mieux fait de payer
des gens pour aller faire des
conférences ou d'aller parler dans les
clubs au niveau des fédérales des ligues
régionales etc
sensibiliser les entraîneurs qu'est ce
qu'on fait quand on a un joueur qui
vient nous voir reprendre des produits
quand comment comment l'aide
comment le détourne comment lui offre
une solution pour pas qu'ils tombent
dans la dans la machine et c'est vrai
que parfois aussi il ya des bas comme on
l'a dit les problèmes d'image qu'on
renvoie le dopage dans les salles de
muscu c'est plus l'image de soi et c'est
vrai que c'est plus une histoire de
psychologie qu'une histoire de co2 de
dopage aux phalanges très rapidement
reagan et raffinement quelque chose qui
pourrait être pas mal serré que des
sanctions beaucoup beaucoup plus
exemplaires là il ya un contrôle il ya
un sportif master cycliste qui vient de
se faire contrôler au canada et a pris
huit ans de suspension
donc les angles pour vous voilà je pense
que voilà
deux ans de suspension c'est ridicule
voilà quand on arrive à des à des gars
comme ça où on est huit ans je pense que
c'est pas mal si jamais mais qu'il a 20
ans il va être utile persian je ne vous
ai pas coupé pour cette dernière
intervention
c'est presque la fin de cette émission
merci nous avoir suivis tout au long de
la saison mais on regarde juste avant de
se quitter
ce best-of une petite sa raquette pour
répondre aux questions vous avez le
choix entre eux oui ou non il ya
également une petite ardoise et yahoo
pour nous présenter cette petite ardoise
voilà même si vous faites vous faites
dans cette émission le gars des
hauts-plateaux tellement les grandes
chaînes de télévision lui font des ponts
d'or pour le recruter genlis est avec
nous c'est une rumeur ou pas au jour une
gueuse alors non je ne sais pas on est
obligé pas eu de contact au moins oral
téléphoner la non non non mais ce soir
elle plusieurs c'était sur ce tout petit
c'est quand même un réel plaisir d'être
ici
vous le connaissez des gens mais tous
syli national
les écuries à deux plaisirs on le
surnomme sur ce plateau le zorro yves
binois notre vengeur masqué qui est venu
sans masque aujourd'hui raul que très de
trith avec nous m'ont soit raul
il est le michael jordan de la répartie
le zii date des analyses de michael
phelps des duels c'est un mythe d'une
légende vivante que dis-je
monument adhésives in il maestro
moustapha al harb à 8 avec nous pour
cette émission
on est très heureux de vous recevoir
moustapha sur cette émission peut
écouter mais aussi avec des
présentations comme celle là j'adore
clairement on peut continuer l'émission
pour le moment tout va bien c'est l'une
des meilleures putsch en ile de france 2
cold and ne vous laissez pas séduire par
ses yeux en amande et ses airs de gentil
fig
elle n'hésite pas être piquant quand il
le prurit elle s'était trompée
maintenant tu as su que j'étais rouge
[Musique]
jeudi vers l'art qui s'effondre ça fait
beaucoup beaucoup plus de bruit que
qu'une pelouse qui poussent là en
l'occurrence c'est la garde de fin de
saison droit c'est vrai ça leur jeu là
c'est moins intéressé par les valides et
elle est validée suite dit oui tu peux
oui il faut que je suis d'accord avec
les britanniques
[Musique]
ah la la
parce qu'au bout
audrey vous allez y aller à la ryder cup
est ce que si on vous dit demain s'il y
aura là une enquête dans deux ans on a
dit oui pour vous bah écoute et
j'attends les situez vous pourriez être
intéressé
cinq minutes le connaissance juste avant
de pouvoir remonter c'est pas c'est pas
tous les jours qu'on voit donc c'est pas
évident ça c'est sûr chose l'offre si
vous le ferez part de michael je viens
avec plaisir c'est plus compliqué son
combat parce que les arbitres appelés à
abandonner les papas pour les papas donc
peu budapest
ça fait pas super rêver je connais pas
je n'étais pas super rêvé par contre ça
q los angeles alors le cio va se
prononcer sur les envies de voyage de
voilà merci à los angeles par contre à
givet les prochaines mois pour
l'échappée leinster donc voilà j'ai en
plus puissants on a besoin de chaussures
lorsqu'on a besoin de gains sade et
quand il fait froid on se protège
puisque notre corps comme est passé tout
l'hiver français ou européen sur miss
vous aiderez ce personnage est tombé
amoureux il est perché construit et mais
c'est quand même ce qu'avait quelqu'un
de deux exceptionnels
hier auprès d'un voire deux comme ça
c'est un petit peu les jean claude van
damme du marathon oil alors basques ont
prescrit au congo jean célèbre sa
victoire dimanche en faisant ça sur le
poteau de transformation c'est ça on a
parlé d'imagés est mort le sport
pratiqué par défi c'est ainsi que des
garçons l'idée générale c'est de
pratiquer le sport c'est pas de dire
faut qu'on se rassemble fin il me semble
ou alors complet en fait j'en voulais
qu'elle est orientée calme revienne mais
bon à poissy reviendra moins qu'à saint
géry allez-y il était un fan de waele
ouais je suis oui bah oui moi d'ailleurs
y'a qu'à voir j'ai jamais fait j'allais
traverser mais bon c'était pas la même
chose
j'en ris pour le futur encore une
nouvelle fois sur sur ces thèmes au
staff pour son sort alors une petite
réaction par rapport à cette saison
yann fériés ces abuseurs dans le best-of
oui j'aime ou defeat et encore une fois
je suis pas venu assez mais non c'est
super sympa rationnelle ça fait plaisir
de voir que ba natation ont fait ça dans
la bonne humeur et qu'on est là juste
pour juste pour le plaisir
jean vous êtes la star de son best-of
qu'elles vivent à dédier à vous non mais
c'est eux qui me souffler les conneries
moi je vous assure hélène bossy ça m'a
bien fait rire mais monde quand même dix
ans et parlait plutôt vers la fin vous
de l'émission par contre la fin de la
saison
oui mais il ya déjà des petits dossiers
gênants mais il manque l'histoire du mal
dumas et les raccords
quand la différentes sélections avec
anderson cette saison vous l'avez vécu
vous de l'intérieur du coup cette saison
il dit noise disparaît minois c'est
souvent c'est vrai que c'est toujours un
plaisir de venir discuter des sujets
sportifs avec tous les collègues on
rigole bien et c'est toujours une bonne
émission dans la bonne humeur et viendra
avec plaisir la saison prochaine je me
souviens d'un fou rire je vais jetter la
juge avait des larmes aux yeux il
n'était pas la caméra mais je pleurais
je n'arrivais plus à me retenir une
connerie de genlis bien sûr si nansion
sport le sport et binoy quand même
c'était une belle saison jean mm même si
vous quittez plaisir vous ne regrettez
pas à non pas du tout pas du tout hein
c'est c'est quand même département qui
est riche mais on n'avait qu'à guérir
vraiment sur les la première saison je
me souviens qu'on avait eu un paquet de
clubs champions qui sont descendus on a
vu beaucoup beaucoup de résultats là on
souhaite à tous ces clubs là qui ont
réussi à monter ou à faire de boire et à
dd confirmer l'année prochaine et on va
on les suivra encore avec avec grand
plaisir
il y aura encore des sports à découvrir
comme le la pole dance
on a découvert cette année avec vous du
coup ça c'est ça et on attend ta petite
démonstration michael évidemment j'ai pu
tester
pas de vidéo malheureusement merci à
tous les quatre en tout cas d'être passé
sur ce plateau cette année merci à tous
les autres chroniqueurs qui sont passés
également tout au long de la saison
c'est la fin de cette émission et c'est
la fin de cette saison très bon été sur
tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]